it as Joe Biden said I think it's a very
difficult decision and it's very
difficult to have a sort of unitary
opinion about it our country along with
many others have banned cluster weapons
from personal experience when I was
commander British forces we went into
Kosovo in 1999 the only two soldiers
that we lost were as a result of
unexploded Munitions from NATO cluster
weapons which at that stage was still
allowed to be used I think the other
issue is one of timing I can understand
why the Americans want to provide this
additional Firepower to Ukraine to help
its counter-offensive along but as we're
coming up with the Vilnius NATO Summit
where one of the most important things
is that we show the unity of NATO
together I think to announce deployment
of these weapons at this moment when so
many other NATO countries have banned
them runs the risk of having a
conversation just Anna as such as we're
having now about whether this is a good
idea whether it's the right idea and it
runs the risk of fracturing to an extent
but but NATO Harmony but as Joe Biden
said and I've just said it's a difficult
decision I think on balance it's
probably the right thing to do but I'm
not alone in being deeply uncomfortable
about having to go to this measure just
because the ukrainians are running out
of ammunition and the Americans and and
ourselves have not been able to ramp up
our own Industrial Supply quick enough
to provide the ukrainians with the more
conventional type of Weaponry that they
have been using and we've been gifting
them up to now
well yes and these Munitions are
contentious because they're deemed so
high risk for civilians so do you think
that the US does lose its high moral
ground by sending them
well you have to think about it um this
war is being fought on Ukrainian
territory quite obviously because the
ukrainians want to throw the Russians
off their territory so it means that
these weapons will be used against
Russian soldiers who are dug in on
Ukrainian territory now we know that
there is a proportion of the
submunitions that don't detonate uh on
Landing now Americans say it's only
three percent uh of theirs uh other
other nations the Russians we criticize
their use of cluster weapons and say it
can be between 30 and 40 percent that
don't go off the point being is that we
are by Design scattering across part of
Ukraine weapons which we know will not
all go off and that there will be more
unexploded ordinance lying around or
parts of Ukraine for many years to come
that takes quite a lot of getting ahead
round
um personally I'm disappointed that we
haven't been able to provide quick
enough all the equipment and ammunition
that Ukraine needs to be able to conduct
this counter-offensive more quickly and
better because we know it's really
important that Ukraine does succeed and
succeed this year so this is a force
measure that divides opinion it's
unfortunate as I said I think the timing
is particularly unfortunate are you
concerned then that the
counter-offensive is going too slowly
and do you think the fact that these
weapons are being sent is a sign of that
um can I check the first part of that
question of first
um it is going slowly but I don't think
we can criticize and Norway should we
criticize the ukrainians for going
slowly uh while we have been training
Ukrainian soldiers uh eventually taking
decisions to provide them with more and
better and more sophisticated largely
Western Equipment the Russians have
spent the same time over the last winter
and this spring uh developing really
deep and complicated defensive positions
now the ukrainians don't want to throw
their young men's lives onto those
prepared defensive positions needlessly
or recklessly in the same way that the
Russians frankly were throwing their
young men at Ukrainian defensive
positions last year so the ukrainians
are going cautiously they're going
carefully they are looking to probe
along the extensive Russian defensive
lines to find weaker points and when
they have found one or two or more
weaker points that's when I think we
will see their attack brigades largely
equipped with Western Equipment um that
they've been preparing we've been
helping with in recent months we'll see
them deployed trying to break in and
break through the Russian positions and
if they're able to do that and are able
to break out Beyond this could then
change the whole nature of the war very
favorably in the ukrainian's favor
uh you mentioned the NATO Gathering next
week
um the UK is pushing for Ukraine to have
its membership of NATO fast tracked
there are reports today that the U.S
could back the UK on that is that
something that you would welcome
well there's no doubt in my mind that
Ukraine should join NATO at some point
and probably at not too much in the
distant future but I think it's it's
very difficult for uh for Ukraine to
join NATO while this is still a hot war
with Russia because if that does happen
then almost by reverse engineering
Article 5 it would actually bring all
the other NATO member nations into the
war that's currently ongoing in Ukraine
against Russia so I think what we should
do is do all that we can to help Ukraine
conclude this war and as soon as that is
done we should then invite Nate uh we
should then invite Ukraine to join NATO
but Vilnius in the next few days they
need to be shown a clear path uh at the
end of that path is an invitation to
join NATO but I think reasonable people
would accept that it would be foolhardy
and playing into the Russians propaganda
if we were invite Ukraine to join NATO
while the war is still hot because the
Russians could then say even more loudly
than they are saying now well this war
isn't just against Ukraine this is now
the whole West the whole of NATO
fighting Russia and that if anything was
going to unite the Russian people
against the West I think that would so
we need to be cautious but also
encourage Ukraine that there is light at
the end of the tunnel that tunnel is
only as long as this war remains hot
General lowdana we appreciate your time
this morning and your thoughts thanks
very much indeed thanks Adam